Lisa Marie Presley will be honored with
a public Memorial at Graceland it's like
this is your life and all in one room in
a statement to ET Monday Lisa Marie's
rep revealed that a public memorial
service will be held on the front lawn
of the Presley Family Estate in Memphis
on Sunday January 22nd at 9 00 a.m the
singer-songwriter died last week after
going into cardiac arrest at her LA area
home now her rep says the Presley family
is grateful for the support well wishes
and outpouring of Love they've received
in the wake of her sudden death in lieu
of flowers Lisa Marie's family asks that
donations be made to the Elvis Presley
charitable Foundation which offers
support to various organizations in
Memphis and its surrounding area
this all comes after E.T learned that
Lisa Marie will be laid to rest at
Graceland alongside her father Elvis
Presley and her late son Benjamin Keough
who died by suicide in 2020 at age 27.
at the time of her death Lisa Marie was
still the sole owner of the Elvis
Memphis mansion and its 13-acre grounds
is absolutely 100 mine always has been
mine Graceland always will be Lisa Marie
sold off most of the Elvis estate in
2004 but kept the family home it's no
longer mine it with my children's you
know that's that Lisa Marie is survived
by her children 33 year old Riley Keough
and 14 year old twin daughters Harper
and Finley Lockwood a rep for the late
singer confirms what Lisa Marie told E.T
Graceland will be inherited by her
daughters they love it there so they
just love it and
love the golf carts love the horses and
love eating there and love their family
they love their family they have a lot
of cousins there and stuff so they love
that
of course the property was heavily
featured in bazlerman's Elvis biopic and
while promoting the film Austin Butler
who plays the king of rock and roll
opened up to E.T inside the gold record
room
Elvis is so loved and so iconic you feel
you feel responsibility playing any
human that has actually lived but with
him it's it's like it's it's a weight
like I never felt before what was it
like watching Austin on stage and during
this movie it was mind-blowing truly
mind-blowing I really didn't know what
what to do with myself after after I saw
it E.T was with Austin and Lisa Marie at
the Golden Globes just two days before
she died I had to take like five days to
process it
because it was so incredible and so spot
on
and so authentic I can't even describe
what it meant following her death Austin
told ET in a statement that his heart is
completely shattered adding that he will
forever cherish her warmth her love and
her authenticity also remembering Lisa
Marie Cheryl Lee Ralph who honored her
late friend with this reminder on Sunday
at the Critics Choice Awards
sad to say I was so close to Lisa Marie
and now she's gone you know it just
proves life is short love the people you
love and love on them
[Music]
foreign